well let's speak to Jessica Washington
who's live in Malang where the Stampede
happened and Jessica can you tell us a
little bit more about the investigation
well the investigation is underway and
part of that of course involves looking
at the state of the kandurahan stadium
in Malang where we are now and I just
want to give you a sense of what that
looks like right now because in the
daylight you really get a sense of how
this tragedy unfolded you can see this
ventilation area has been appears to
have been smashed by Spectators as they
tried their best to leave the stadium
once tear gas was fired and this metal
door over here you can see how it's been
bent out of shape because people were
really running for their lives that's
what Spectators have been telling us
that police via tear gas but many of the
exits were shot and so they didn't even
have the opportunity to try to escape
and that's how this pilot began and and
people lost their lives as as the
Stampede happen you can see here people
have been leaving tributes throughout
the weekend and today as well flowers
and candles the community really just in
shock at what has happened what has
unfolded and of course those calls from
adequate and thorough investigation that
investigation still very much underway
but we understand that police are
looking in particular at 18 officers who
had some involvement in firing the tear
gas but the community here is so angry
and they are calling for answers and you
can see signs like this scattered
throughout the stadium
my brother was killed we need a thorough
investigation and there is so much anger
here and so much despair just a shock
that many of the victims of course were
young young men young women families
even you can see their shoes scattered
around and even purses people were
fleeing for their lives and really just
you can see dozens of shoes throughout
the stadium and hear this sign
particularly powerful police evil police
you killed my brother and so people are
looking for answers they're looking for
accountability and it remains to be seen
whether they will ever get that indeed
thank you so much that's Jessica
Washington for us live from from Milan